لكن هناك ازمه اخرى ستؤثر على تسليم
ليوبارد اثنين لاوكرانيا لن يكون بمقدار
برلين تسليم الدبابه الى كيف الا في عام
الشركه المصنعه تؤكد ذلك وتعزل الامر
لتطويرها لكن هل هذا هو الواقع ام انها
منى وراسيه من المانيا وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه ديمترو كوليبا تحدث صادقا عن
السياسه الالمانيه اولا يقولون لا ثم
يدافعون بشده عن قرارهم فقط ليقولون نعم
في النهايه تكرر الامر في ازمه الطاقه
ويتكرر الان لكن
اثنين اكثر من 2000 دبابه في حوزه اثنا
عشر جيشا اوروبيه فهل تستطيع هذه الدول
تسليم الدباباتون موافقه برلين
العقود المبرمات الزم هذه الدول بموافقه
المانيا قبل تزويد الجيش الاوكراني بها
ثانيا لم تتلقى المانيا طلبات حتى الان
بهذا الصدد كما ترفض ضغوط الحلفاء وتضعوا
شرطا اساسيا للتسليم وهو ان تسلم واشنطن
هي الاخرى دبابات ابرامز لكياب لكن اللافت
ان الحكومه الالمانيه اليوم خرجت لتناقض
نفسها لم نربط الامرين ببعضهم
تعاونوا وتنسيق للخلفاء الان النقطه خلافه
وزراء دفاع نيته اليوم لم يتوصلوا لقراءه
اسماعيل
دليل على وجود الخلاف غياب بولندا مثلا
التي تؤكد انها لا تحتاج لضوء برلين
الاخضر واليوم خليجيات وارسو صعدت اكثر
ملوحه باجراء غير تقليدي انعرضت المانيا
الامر الحلفاء اذا لنا ان يضغطون على
المانيا تماما كما تضغط عليهم المعارضه في
الداخل ضغط جعل وزيره الدفاع السابقه
تستقيل ومن حل بدل عنها رجل من نفس الحزب
لكن هناك اختلاف قد يفجر ازمه جديده
الوزير الجديد مؤيد
لم تصمد وزيره الدفاع الالمانيه كريستينا
لمروجت في منصبها اكثر من عام واحد فالمه
التي سلمها اياها المستشار الالماني اولاف
شونس تبين او تحولت الى مهمه صعبه ومتعبه
عكس ما كانت تتخيل لمرش عندما وافقت على
العدول عن التقاعد والتسلل حقيبه الدفاع
ولكن الحرب في اوكرانيا حولت هذه الوزاره
الى واحده من اهم الوزارات داخل الحكومه
الالمانيه خاصه بعد قرار المستشار اعاده
تاهيل الجيش الالماني الهرم لكي يمكنه من
مواجهه اي اعتداءنا محتمل ضد المانيا فشلت
لمبرجت بالمهمه سريعا والتهمت بالبطئ وعدم
يفهم الحاجات الجيش الالماني وحتى التغيب
عن العمل لاسباب خاصه فاستقالت امام
الانتقادات والضغوط المتزايده حل مكانها
سريعا وزير داخليه ولا ساكسونيا السفلى
بوليس بيس توريوس الذي تقع على عاتقه الان
مهمه اعاده تاهيل الجيش الالماني واستمرار
التسليح الجيش الاوكراني بالعتاد والاسلحه
والدبابات الالمانيه الصنع التي تطالب بها
كياف ولكن تصريحات ستوريوس السابقه
ومواقفه من روسيا خاصه لجهه دعوته قبل
ثلاثه سنوات لرفع العقوبات عنها قد تعودوا
لتطارده وتعقده من مهمته هو ايضا